[Musique]
ce sera également la première fois que
je fête mon anniversaire en dehors de la
réunion et franchement j'aime bien en
plus c'est un beau panorama autour
niveau c'est un cadre magnifique dans un
bon hôtel ouais c'est ça c'est un
anniversaire que je me sens a donné
toute ma vie
[Musique]
ea pas la barrière de la langue et le
contact il est direct il est déjà dans
leur gardant le sourire et puis dans des
petits contacts et au fur et à mesure
mal à barrière elle s'abaisse et puis
bon bah c'est juste génial la relation
secret le fait d'avoir des étrangers
d'être différent ça montre que
finalement nos différences bas nous
enrichit et les enfants ils sont bien
ils sont sensibles à ça et on le voit
bien c'est que quand on devient adulte
on a tendance à mettre plus de barrières
sociales alors que là ya pas la barrière
et les changes s'est fait tout
naturellement
rapprochement lé voilà les enfants
viennent les gens sont contents et en
plus ça nous permet d'avoir des supers
échanges avec la population parce que du
coup il ya la réciprocité donc nous on
chante on danse et on échange mais aussi
nous offrent leurs champs et et c'est
super
calé et apprendre notre culture ils
n'ont pas l'habitude d'entendre ce genre
de musique ils apprennent à chanter
aussi des poids paille zem venir avec
nous dans ces sans problème
ils sont pas gênés ils sont ils viennent
vers nous quoi
[Musique]
on découvre aussi leur culture parce que
par exemple par la musique on commence à
jouer nos musiques et tout et après des
fois tu les guider tous qui viennent et
qui mettent leurs propres chansons ça
permet à chacune des deux cultures de
découvrir l'autre
tous
période dans votre vie qui sortent de on
l'espère beaucoup une porte d'entrée
vers une autre vie en allant vers la
villa du chef d'agrès cela nous a
beaucoup aidés surtout pour ceux qui
avaient des problèmes de vue nous
souhaitons vous dire un grand merci
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui pour accueillir le
groupe et les remercie vous êtes ici
avec nous vous êtes venus de loin de
différents endroits
et on peut voir aujourd'hui des gens qui
viennent d'un peu partout pour la visite
médicale et ils vous sont très
reconnaissants
anglais mais ils sont très reconnaissant
pour votre aide et surtout pour les
lunettes de vue
ils sont heureux et on le voit on le
ressent vraiment qu'ils sont contents
certaines personnes doivent marcher à
peu près une heure pour vous juste ici
on leur a dit que vous seriez là
aujourd'hui ils se sont organisés pour
être là
deux bogeys
[Musique]